going back to your your the japan trip i
would say that
completely ruined your perception of
like
of of like anime and weebs in general so
do you want to explain like why that
happened or what happened were you the
stereotypical weeb before
everything describe describe yourself
describe what you were like before and
describe
what happened in the description of
course like because i okay
the beginning was like i had a japanese
foreign exchange student because i was
like oh japanese people love nihongo
desu
and it's like kind of like joey dies
inside
my nuts just when he goes
but i i'm definitely up until i think i
met her i calm down a lot i'm like
she's pretty normal
and then she let me stay at her house in
japan after she went back home after a
year
i was 17. um so i went to her house
and then i kind of just went everywhere
in tokyo that was like anything and the
whole time like i loved the trip it was
don't get me wrong but it
did do i think that it was anime you
know heaven here
like do i think like so what was your
image of japan before coming here for
the first time come here and i'd be like
an
instant like everyone be like oh kawaii
blonde
do girl want to be an internet you want
to be an idol in japan just take over
the
country remind us she says she had no
self-confidence once i like
grow up and realize like man [ __ ]
life really hits you like a truck and
then like once i grew up and like
[ __ ] how come i left japan and i wasn't
like prime minister
that's like every white guy where he
goes
and then i then i made like i started
reflecting yeah definitely just on
everything and i'm like
[ __ ] this is anime
normal country and then just like
because like you
you i remember you were telling me
stories about how you were like
cosplayed in
akihabara and stuff like that because
like when i went to
japan it was 2012 and about i think a
year prior or a year and a half prior on
ohana
finished and um we went to and i really
love
anahana like um but um so
i went to the village for uh which is
where it was based off of
and um since i was like the blonde blue
eyed girl they're like oh manma so they
made me like
dress up as men for a picture who made
you dress up
we went to the place that was like
because they were having a festival
on ohana right and then there was like a
street completely dedicated towards like
looking like the anime like they had a
secret base and everything
and um so we went to the store i think
where they were like beginning to run
everything and then people
were just like they're like oh [ __ ] like
we need somebody to like cosplay to gain
more
people to like want to come over and
then uh so they just like
they asked me to find a white girl
and then because i think she's meant to
be white in the anime if i remember like
they were
but why is her name i don't get into
that yeah i think she's supposed to be
japanese
but you know anime being anime is like
let's just make them not japanese yeah
so then they made me wear uh men cost
like
the white dress and um just i don't
think i've ever felt
so wanted
like japanese people just like i just
remember like the flashing like i
couldn't see they're just like telling
me to pose and i was just like
[ __ ] i'm just like like i'm just blonde
hair blue-eyed and wearing a mammoth
dress and i've never felt so loved
jesus went down here you got too much
love or you didn't get anything
didn't you get accused of being racist
oh
why not why not yeah let's just jump
right into it yeah so
i went so okay i when i was studying in
england i quickly had to pick a thing i
wanted to major in
and i just picked japanese all right
i'll say it i
i made your channel of course
and um [ __ ] so i was so i went to
university in london
and um oh god i really hope he doesn't
watch this oh so okay so i had a
japanese professor
and um we'd obviously write essays as
you do in university
yeah and um he let us pick the genre
like what we want to write about exactly
and i picked about like kind of japan's
fascination with westerners and like
kind of their looks to kind of like you
know meet you like stuff like that
and so i i felt really good about it
like i i thought it was the best i ever
wrote
read it he's like i i actually thought
it was a good it was a good essay and
then
i when i was like so excited i'm like
this is the best and like i was
i'd never been so hyped for a grade
you know you did good [ __ ] and you're
like i can't wait to get that [ __ ] a
but then i get like my the grades back
two weeks later and it's a zero out of a
hundred
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] right
yeah and so i messaged him like
why did i get a zero for this he's like
because it was like he never explicitly
said
racist but he's like you are very
insensitive to japanese people and
just like just a lot of stuff and i
remember just like crying because i'm
like oh my god it's so such like calling
me racist
so it was your professor like full
jacket yeah he was full he literally
came like he was older japanese man who
came to like
teach japanese like culture in the
university and uh
yeah maybe he just maybe you just gave
him a pill he couldn't swallow it yeah
yeah yeah
[ __ ] she called me out i called us out
like that
yeah i mean when they when he when you
told me that i'm like but like
every single sign near our house is like
white people yeah
yeah that's what people have it's like
the gym i i don't see a single asian
person
that's all right it's always ripped
white dudes yeah the longer i live here
the more i'm like man i shouldn't have
got a [ __ ] zero
i remember you go back that great and
you're like i had to convince you for
the week that you just weren't racist
maybe i'm racist maybe i'm like you're
like [ __ ] martin luther's just like
i'm just dropping these truth bombs
i just can't handle it legit i was like
convinced i was racist
completely i was convinced i mean what
kind of like
is that how it works [ __ ]
what if i have internal racism and i
never even knew
yeah no but yeah i i
he almost i almost failed university
because of that oh wow
he made me um rewrite it and he actually
gave me good points for i had to write
about i'd read memories didn't you drop
out anyway
i did jokes on you
i wanted that credit so yeah that one
you could argue that the professor was
being racist to you
[ __ ] wow that's a visual
excuse me sir i believe you are the
racist one here
coming that's just 20 20 today yeah
oh my god